سحر [موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي هو الشعور بأنك تحصل على
ليلة عيد الميلاد عندما يأتي سانتا كلوز إلى
منزلك ويقدم لك هدية
البيتانجا الابتسامة على وجوه الأطفال عندما
يظهر الأرنب فجأة وهم يعرفون أن هذا
السحر هو شغفي
وهوايتي إنها مهنتي إنها كل شيء  بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى] ،
مرحبًا بكم في: ميتشجان ، عاصمة السحر
في العالم ، أنا جون ستيرلي نيث
صاحب شركة تصنيع السحر الإسترليني ،
اسمي ريك فيشر ، أنا الرئيس
والمدير التنفيذي لشركة فاب ماجيك ، أنا
جريج بوردنر وأنا  رئيس
سحر أبوت وجلبت معي كتابًا جيدًا
يُدعى الكتاب المقدس أحيانًا
هناك بعض الأجزاء الرائعة حقًا هنا
يوجد بالفعل بعض النار والكبريت
[موسيقى]
هناك ثلاثة متاجر سحرية في:
ميشيغان ونحن على بعد حوالي ثلاث
كتل مباشرة  يوجد بجواري سحر رائع
ويقع سحر أبوت على بعد كتلة واحدة غربنا ،
وهناك الكثير من
الأشياء الصغيرة هنا: هناك قبعات علوية
في الشارع تتفتح فيها الزهور ،
ولدينا بيتزا بيتزا واحدة  Arlor لدينا
محطتان للوقود ، لدينا ضوء وامض واحد فقط
[موسيقى]
لدينا سحرة مشهورون ، إنه
يشبه إلى حد ما
ممشى المشاهير في هوليوود لدينا تميمة مدرستنا الثانوية هي
Fighting Magi ، وهناك أجهزة المدينة السحرية ،
وهناك أوهام للعناية بالشعر
ولدينا ثلاثة متاجر سحرية في بلدة
تضم 1200 شخصًا
، بدأ سحر أبوت في تنفيذ
الاتفاقية السحرية 80 منذ بضع سنوات ، كان لدينا
آلاف السحرة من جميع أنحاء
العالم الذين يجتمعون هنا لتعلم مشاركة
معرفتهم بالسحر
عند أدائك  خدعة سحرية
وطفل صغير يبتسم ويذهب مبهرًا يمكنك
أن ترى السحر في وجهه الذي هو
حقًا أفضل جزء قبل ذلك 15
دقيقة ، نأمل أن تأخذ هذا
الشخص من هذا العالم إلى هذا العالم الذي
قلته دائمًا لوالدي حتى
طفل صغير سأنتقل إلى هنا في أحد
هذه الأيام وسأمتلك
متجرًا للسحر أصبح حقيقةً
[موسيقى]
أنت